for the fifth year in a row kylie jenner
is the youngest member of the forbes
list of america's richest self-made
women jenner part of the extended
kardashian clan and the founder of kylie
cosmetics is at age 24 one of just 11
people on the new 2022 forbes list who
are under age 40.
altogether the under 40s are worth an
estimated 6 billion dollars 5 percent of
the list total 111 billion dollars
jenner ranks number 41 on this year's
list up from number 51 in 2021 though
forbes estimates that her fortune has
declined by about 20 million dollars
from a year ago to 600 million dollars
partially due to the drop in values of
cosmetics firms amid the spring stock
market route jenner sold 51 of her
company to beauty giant cody in 2019 and
walked away with an estimated 540
million dollars before taxes
three of america's youngest self-made
women are new to the ranking this year
that includes this year's second
youngest self-made woman 27 year old
lucy guo who co-founded artificial
intelligence firm scale ai and held onto
a stake after she left the firm is now
valued at 7.3 billion dollars
also new to the list is rachel drory who
founded plant-based frozen meal delivery
company daily harvest and is 39 years
old she debuts after investors valued
her company at 1.1 billion dollars late
last year
in late june daily harvest recalled
their french lentil and leaked crumbles
due to consumer reports of
gastrointestinal illness and potential
liver function issues
emma greed ceo of fashion brand good
american and founding partner and chief
product officer of kim kardashian
shapewear firm skims is also 39. she
joins the list at number 77 and is the
second youngest black woman on the list
with an estimated 360 million dollar
fortune
another of the youngest barbados first
billionaire 34 year old rihanna whose 50
stake in makeup line fenty beauty makes
her along with greed one of two black
women under 40 to make the list
she comes in at number 21 with a 1.4
billion dollar fortune she's the only
woman under 40 on the list who's a
billionaire and is the youngest
self-made billionaire in america
former tennis player maria sharapova has
rejoined the rank after dropping off in
2021 brand endorsement deals and savvy
investments land her at number 97 with
an estimated 220 million dollar fortune
making her the only athlete under 40 on
the list rachel carlson whose company
guild education has landed contracts
with big names like disney walmart and
chipotle over the past few years owns an
estimated 15 of the company landing her
at number 54 on this year's list
after forbes finalized our list guild
education raised 175 million dollars
from investors who now value the company
at 4.4 billion dollars up from 3.7
billion dollars last year
[Music]
[Music]
you